so
not be talking just about ideas but the
actually be
expressing the idea is there you know
somebody in the
maybe you can comment there's a guy uh
his youtube channel is
three blue one brown grant sanderson he
does
that masterfully well absolutely of uh
visualizing of expressing a particular
idea and then talking about it as well
back and forth uh what do you what do
you think about grant
it's fantastic i mean the flowering of
math youtube is like such a wonderful
thing because
you know math teaching there's so many
different venues
through which we can teach people math
there's the traditional one right
where i'm in a classroom with you know
depending on the class it could be 30
people it could be 100 people
it could god help maybe 500 people if
it's like the big calculus lecture or
whatever it may be
and there's sort of some but there's
some set of people of that order of
magnitude
and i'm with them for we have a long
time i'm with them for a whole semester
and i can ask them to do homework and we
talk together we have office hours that
they have one-on-one questions a lot of
play that's like a very high level of
engagement
but how many people am i actually
hitting at a time like not
that many right um and you can
and there's kind of an inverse
relationship where the
more and g the the fewer people you're
talking to the more engagement you can
ask for
the ultimate of course is like the
mentorship relation of like a
phd advisor and a graduate student where
you spend a lot of
one-on-one time together for like you
know three to five years
and the ultimate high level of
engagement to one person
um you know books
i can this can get to a lot more people
that are ever going to sit in my
classroom and you spend like uh
however many hours it takes to read a
book somebody like three blue one brown
or number file or
people like vi heart i mean youtube
let's face it
has bigger reach than a book like
there's youtube videos that have many
many many more views than like
you know any hardback book like not
written by a kardashian or an obama is
going to sell right so that's
i mean um any and
and then you know those are you know
some of them are like
longer 20 minutes long some of them are
five minutes long but they're you know
they're shorter and then even so
look look like eugenia chang who's a
wonderful category theorist in chicago i
mean
she was on i think the daily show or i
mean she was on you know
she has 30 seconds but then there's like
30 seconds to sort of say something
about math mathematics to like untold
millions of people so everywhere along
this curve isn't is important one
thing i feel like is great right now is
that people are just broadcasting on all
the channels because we each have
our skills right somehow along the way
like i learned how to write books i had
this
kind of weird life as a writer where i
sort of spent a lot of time like
thinking about how to put
english words together into sentences
and sentences together into paragraphs
like
at length which is this kind of like
weird specialized scale
and that's one thing but like sort of
being able to make like you know
winning good looking eye-catching videos
is like a totally
different skill and you know probably
you know somewhere out there there's
probably sort of some like
heavy metal band that's like teaching
math through heavy metal and like using
their skills
to do that i hope there is at any rate
through and so on yeah
but there is something to the process i
mean grant does this
especially well which is
in order to be able to visualize
something now he writes
programs so it's programmatic
visualization so like the
the things he is basically mostly
through his uh
madam library in python everything is
drawn
through python you have to um
you have to truly understand the topic
to be able to
to visualize it in that way and not just
understand it but
really kind of think in a very novel way
it's funny because i i've spoken with
them a couple times i've spoken to him a
lot offline as well
he really doesn't think he's doing
anything new
meaning like he sees himself as very
different from maybe like a researcher
but it feels to me
like he's creating something totally new
like that act of understanding
visualizing
is as powerful or has the same kind of
inkling of power as does the process of
proving something
you know it just it doesn't have that
clear destination
but it's it's pulling out an insight and
creating
multiple sets of perspective that arrive
at that insight
and to be honest it's something that i
think we haven't quite
figured out how to value inside academic
mathematics in the same way and this is
a bit older that i think we haven't
quite
figured out how to value the development
of computational infrastructure you know
we all have computers as our partners
now and people
build computers that sort of assist and
participate in our mathematics they
build those systems and that's
a kind of mathematics too but not in the
traditional form of
proving theorems and writing papers but
i think it's coming look i mean i think
you know for example the institute for
uh computational experimental
mathematics at brown which is like a
you know it's a nsf-funded math
institute very much part of sort of
traditional math academia they did an
entire theme semester about visualizing
mathematics looking to the same kind of
thing that they would do for like
an up-and-coming research topic like
that's pretty cool so i think there
really is
buy-in from uh the mathematics community
to recognize that this kind of stuff is
important and counts as
part of mathematics like part of what
we're actually
here to do yeah i'm hoping to see more
and more of that from like
mit faculty from faculty from all the
the top universities in the world
you